congratulations you guys you have done
it again
you have topped the last one I didn't
know how you could do it you keep
topping the one before Congrats how are
you feeling good the movie opens quickly
with that iconic you got a friend in me
theme song and it took me back the
nearly 25 years to when we were first
introduced to these characters you guys
what kind of nostalgia do you experience
and do you feel each time you revisit
your characters I can't talk about it
but it's got to be real emotional up
front I thought it was a risky move and
it paid off it gets emotional right at
the start then it gets ends off there's
wonderful it's just a great story
introduce all the new toys are better
than some of the old toys and it's just
not better they're just impression it's
great and the story just climbs and
overall it's stunning to look at that's
what I felt the animation quality itself
it's so beautiful that's think the
antique store the level of detail in the
toys I love the process you know as a
Tom and I said 25 years of this I still
number one is my favorite because it was
number one it was the first it
introduced us to this but boy have these
guys expanded the storage they are we
were at Disney Land and we were to say
there's there's a a knight lead there's
a felt at what is it fantasy in the sky
comes it and it closes with every Disney
character in history dancing on the Mark
Twain steamboat as it goes around Tom
Sawyer's Island and there is Mickey and
Donald and Daisy
although Pluto Peter Pan Captain Hook
all the princesses and there was Buzz
and Woody as well dancing on the back
and my daughter who was in her 30s burst
into tears because she realized that
some version of her dad is going to be a
Disneyland for the rest of eternity and
that so I you don't discount that that's
a powerful thing
well done how much pressure is there to
join something that it's already so
beloved like this a lot I think to be on
the journey that Tim and Annie and and
Tom started is such an honor it's kind
of one of those things like has somebody
made a mistake well they're thinking of
another Tony where they're thinking of
Tony Danza you know I didn't know what
exactly was happening at first sounds
like you know what it was turns out
every kind of wave of it I kind of wake
up to it and it's pretty exciting we get
to be introduced to them when we go to
work and we have an explanation of who
for key is going to be in Gabby Gabby
and kaboom and it's it just kicks the
whole experience into a higher gear
[Music]
crisis himself you know he's called for
key if you want to look at these talking
points there's an explanation I think we
all say why isn't it called we're
talking about we're gonna call you
but that thing that we can say exists
and this character is coming to life and
its essence is when it's being created
has its own identity right as four key
he's a spool yes yeah I know okay so
there's a road trip adventure that it
revolves around who out of this group
would you most trust to drive the
Winnebago Annie oh you have probably and
each had a button like buzz to express
your inner thoughts out loud
what would your say right now roadie
baby any Stabler
go to the next person I can't think of
something right wanna know it I got it /
- mine will be what's happening now get
out of the party here we go
Oh more or less on the same how special
was that for you when you realize that
was what it was going to be well I like
that quite a bit
I think it's spot on for a fantastic
message for little girls and I have
three sons it's like they do not mess
with me and they should not mess with my
mama but don't mess with Mama and
there's also this theme that woody feels
that his time is over that he has
fulfilled his purpose and what is next
have you guys ever pondered that in the
course of your lives or your careers I
believe that's called staying in the
moments being present there is yesterday
and there's today and then we got a good
shot at making the right decision
tomorrow but let's see what I have met
older gentleman in my life that I want
to be like that that's what go out like
a lion that's that's all I think of that
as a couple old men in my life that
don't say anything to anybody ever and
they have a quiet serenity and they've
lived a great life and I wish I could be
like that as I as I continue I really
that's been a real important part of my
life thanks for killing that little
girls your most pretty
[Music]
[Applause]